I'm sure you've picked up by now
that there can be all sorts of
problems with data.
To build a great analytic data set,
you need to be aware of the data issues,
know what to look for, and what to do.
We've covered off how to fix dirty data,
such as data that needs to be parsed,
extra characters removed or deduped.
We've also covered a couple of
methods in dealing with missing data,
like deletion and amputation.
And lastly,
we looked at how to identify outliers,
why it's important to understand them,
and how to deal with them.
Now that we know how to clean
up our dirty, missing, and
anomalous data,
it's time to move on to formatting data.
In the next lesson, we'll look at
a couple of methods used to massage data
into formats required to build
out our final analytic data set.